[Music]
hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
talking about pookie-kai 10 so that's
the high fall you see in Aikido Luca Tai
Chi 10 is probably one of the reasons
that Aikido got so popular so I remember
when I was a kid
early on watching TV and seeing people
throw like a judo style of people
throwing a 92 style and thinking like
whoa Aikido looks way more powerful than
judo because some guy just moves like
this and the guy flips through the air
and it's this big powerful thing so
there's a lot of myth and mysticism in
pookie-kai 10 and it's not all for show
there's a good reason for the kooky
chitin and today we're gonna get into it
and talk about why high falls are your
friend and why you need to do them and
and also kind of take away some of the
mystery of what they actually are so I'm
gonna call Josh out here and we're gonna
go to work for you guys all right so
we're gonna talk about high falls and
why they exist in IQ so high Falls are
probably the reason for awhile but a lot
of people studied Aikido because high
Falls look impressive so if you see a
teacher grab someone and they go like
this now all of a sudden you're like
that guy must be so friggin strong he
just flipped that guy and it was amazing
and all that was so awesome and I don't
want to put people like that so I got to
do like to know because I need to flip
people like that alright so I'm going to
make some people sad here probably with
this if you've never thrown you on a
high fall that's not happening because I
am so powerful it's happening because
josh is in a bad position and if he
doesn't do the high fall he's going to
hurt himself in some way so it's not
because I throw amazingly it's because
Josh jumps over so he doesn't hurt
myself and let me explain so so if
you're a normal person I'm gonna ask you
to fall like a normal person which give
me painful push your release all right
so here's what a normal person does if
someone pushes you down and you start
falling towards the ground
you stick your arms out like this to
catch yourself so if I push Josh
okay that's that's kind of Jeff still
did it really nice because he doesn't he
doesn't like doing its stupid idea this
is what we all do though because when we
were babies and we learned to walk and
you weighed you know ten pounds and you
went like this you wouldn't break your
arm right so that was a good way to
stick your arm and like oh you know so
when you when you fall most people have
a tendency to stick their arm out now
the problem with this is you're very
likely to hurt your shoulder your elbow
or your wrist when you do this because
any one of those joints can get locked
up and all of your body weights going
down so it's a bad way to fall but
that's how most people have fall they'd
stick their arm out like that okay now
once you've learned how to fall a little
bit you'll fall like this so if I shove
ja okay now notice what Josh did he did
all the right things there he rounded
his spine he landed on his butt she
tucked his chin and he rolled and
distributed the way in in a rolling
action whether he actually does a roll
or not that kind of action distributes
that force a little better and no one
part of his body takes too much force so
that's a really great way to fall okay
now if I had Josh in a position like
this okay it's impossible for him to
stick his arm down because I'm holding
it so if I'm pushing him this way he
can't stick his arm down okay it's also
possible for him to fall rounding his
spine so if he did a side break fall
like this by shoved him he kind of just
side break also it'd be a side great
fall that would be cool and that would
be a good way to fall but because I'm
holding him he can't do that so it
really means when he falls very likely
he's gonna smash directly into his
shoulder or directly in his head so I'm
pushing at the ground like that that's
where he's gonna fall that's right there
on his head or his shoulder so he
doesn't want to do that so what Josh
does is allows his body to come all the
way over and hit on the other side just
like that now when he falls like that he
can distribute his way evenly on the
opposite side of his body so basically
what happened was I put him in a
precarious position where following
means he would have smashed his shoulder
really hard or smashed his head so
instead of doing that Josh chooses to
jump over and land on the other side of
his body now this looks phenomenal right
and so probably due to a lot of
popularity of Aikido is because everyone
thinks that Aikido masters are so great
and they can throw so hard but when you
see that you shouldn't be complementing
the Aikido expert you should be
complimenting the guy who's falling
because you guys falling
actually knows how to fall in a way to
keep himself from getting hurt when he's
being pushed
into a precarious position so the
position is being pushed into is
dangerous for him but it's not because
the Aikido nage the person doing the
throwing is throwing so forcefully that
happens the guy who's being thrown
chooses to jump over so that way he can
distribute his weight better so this is
a breaking up a little bit of the myth
of high balls after this we're gonna
teach you how to fight ball so if you
want to learn how to high fall we're
gonna talk about all kinds of ways to
learn to high fall in the in the
following videos I'm Christopher Hine
thanks for watching
[Music]